hey guys do you struggle with dark
circles under your eyes well i've been
struggling with it for years
and that's why i learned how to get rid
of them so in this video i'm gonna give
you my seven best tips to get rid of
dark circles under your eyes let's not
waste any more time let's get to the
video
[Music]
all right guys now first you need to
understand what creates those dark
circles under your eyes in the first
place what are the causes
you need to understand that because then
you'll be better equipped to prevent it
from happening in the first place and we
know that prevention is always better
than cure so let's take a look at
sun damage yeah it's true this just
basically comes from being in the sun
for years unprotected sun damage if you
like being in the sun especially tanning
it will lead to excess pigmentation that
shows through the thin layer of skin
underneath your eyes
now i've said this in previous videos
but i'll say it here again in case you
missed it if you go into the sun what
happens well you get vitamin d and then
after a while your body turns brown
right or it gets darker do you know why
because your body produces melanin when
you are in the sun and melanin is the
pigment that gives your skin its color
so to solve this issue it's simple just
don't go out in the sun too much and if
you do just get some protection use
sunblock or get face cream with sunblock
in it
blood flow underneath your eyes you know
this skin here underneath your eyes the
blood flow underneath that delicate skin
it kind of shines through so then it
appears as if you have dark circles
under your eyes now the right or smart
term for this
is vascular dark circles
now you can't really do anything about
this but some of the tips at the end of
this video might help
horse or skin aggravating ingredients
this is really bad for your skin for
your face when you do your skincare
routine and you use these products
especially products with fragrances in
it all you got to do is very simple
is just stay away from it
[Music]
allergies this is a strange one but yeah
it is true allergies can also give you
dark circles under your eyes
deep said eyes if you have deep set eyes
like i do
then what basically happens is they give
you more shadows underneath your eyes so
then it appears as if you have dark
circles and unfortunately it's just in
your dna so you can't do anything about
this one
buildup of dehydrated skin there's a few
things that can cause dehydrated skin
like not drinking enough water the
weather air conditioning a bad diet bad
lifestyle choices like drinking too much
alcohol or caffeine
lack of sleep too hot showers and
forgetting or skipping your skincare
routine now this is simple all you gotta
do is just live a healthy lifestyle and
then get a good skincare routine that
fits in with your unique skin i'll talk
more about this later in the video
rubbing the skin around the eyes a lot
of people got this bad habit to rub
their eyes like this you know when it's
itchy or when they are tired but instead
just go to the bathroom go and do your
skincare routine feel fresh wash it and
then won't itch that much if you do this
then you gotta stop because it steadily
damages that soft sensitive skin around
your eyes if you keep on doing it you'll
get saggy eyes as you grow older and
you'll have dark circles i used to do
this myself a lot when i was younger
until i decided to stop
and break the habit
lack of sleep now most of you already
know this so i'm not going to talk about
this one too long but if you don't sleep
enough it can make those existing dark
circles look even worse so all you got
to do is just get some sleep
[Music]
loss of fat thinning skin and collagen
now this usually comes with age as you
grow older you know those red blue blood
vessels underneath your eyes it comes
out more and then of course if it stands
out more it looks like you have dark
circles under your eyes all you got to
do for this one is just don't get older
alright guys so what are the best ways
to get rid of dark circles underneath
their eyes apart from these causes and
solutions that i've already talked about
well in all honesty which is what my
channel is known for honesty
you won't really get rid of your dark
circles 100
but there are a few things that you can
do to make it look a lot better let's
start with the first one
tea bags but not just any tea bags
caffeinated tea bags like green tea all
you gotta do is soak two tea bags in
warm water and then just chill them a
little bit in the refrigerator until it
has cooled down then just put them on
your eyes and leave it for around 5
minutes the caffeine will help shrink
the blood vessels and will reduce the
dark circles and puffiness under your
eyes
[Music]
sunglasses always wear sunglasses when
you go outside it's definitely going to
protect you from the sun sunscreen is
also effective but the sunglasses will
protect that delicate skin under your
eyes 100 percent
antihistamine this is for you guys with
allergies you can easily get it over the
counter and this will not only help with
dark circles but with puffy eyes
[Music]
a good skincare routine now earlier i
talked about the buildup of dehydrated
skin as one of the causes for those dark
circles under your eyes now this is so
easy to fix with a good skin care
routine good skin care products that
includes and this is important that
includes sun protection now over the
years i mentioned a few good products
like pc for men
tj hanley clinique and my favorite
geology now geology is awesome because
it enables you to customize your own
unique skincare products with skin care
experts all you got to do when you
select your skin concerns on their
website is to click the dark circles
button and they will include ingredients
that will help you with it it is that
simple then they will send you your
skincare routine you'll get two face
washes one you can keep in the shower
and the other on the zinc you get a
daytime moisturizer and a repairing
night cream and then finally
eye cream now i've got a very good
relationship with them and i got you
guys 30 discount off your first purchase
i've added my code for you in the video
description down below but if you just
want one item specifically for your eyes
you can try something with a bha levon
exfoliant retinol serum and a good eye
cream or gel that contains peptides now
if all of this is confusing don't worry
i've added everything for you in the
video description down below so it's
easier for you to go and check it out
[Music]
something else you can try is skin
lightening products with two percent
hydroquinone it is definitely gonna help
those dark circles caused by sun damage
you can also try a brightening product
now this will help with the luminosity
and also the vibrancy under your eyes
vitamin c products will help and you can
also try polish choice skincare resist
pure radiant skin brightening treatment
wow that was a mouthful
now lastly the in-office treatments now
this is only
a last resort kind of thing and there
are a lot that you can you can try but
let me just mention a few ipl
this stands for intense pulsed light
then there's radio frequency q switched
ruby lasers pulse dyed lasers dermal
fillers fat transfers
blepharoplasty this is a cosmetic
surgery and then there's chemical peels
with salicylic acid bha but as i said
this is a last resort kind of thing and
i i won't do this myself
but if you have a serious problem with
dark circles under your eyes go and see
your dermatologist get some expert
advice now if you want more tips on skin
care you can watch this video here or if
you like vlogs you can watch this one
here and i'll see you there now remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys